we should probably looking at
exponential growth and decay in
situations where we either are growing
from a step zero all with decay into a
stem zero like radioactive decay like
eventually in the whole of substance
eventually enough the peruvians abuse
that they will disappear it'll be gone
right so when you think about the
exponential decay graph what it's
looking at it's looking like lava is
something like this without asymptotes
right on the axis we go down to zero
but in a number of important situations
for which I have on the board and there
are others of you can choose from later
there are various environmental factors
that may you don't go down to zero okay
so what we have a hot object right and
you put it in an NP temperature that is
lower or actually in reverses you've got
a cold object like you pull something
out of the fridge and you did someone
and it starts to warm up right that's
not you change the temperature of that
object and change not it's not gonna go
zero like you're not going to take your
own cup of coffee out of the out of the
microwave and then it's not just going
to go to zero degrees Celsius support
like prison cup of coffee right it will
come down to whatever the ambient
temperature happens to be right so
there's an environmental factor which
means it doesn't do this yeah terminal
velocity if you've thrown objects from a
grapevine right it's going to speed up
and it's going to speed up you know sort
of exponential growth and decay kind of
way but it's not going to speed up
forever it's not going to speed up
indefinitely
terminal velocity means if you relate
someone here with physical copy I think
it's the force of gravity and drag and
buoyancy buoyancy like how moieties once
you put all these things together there
will be a sense thing which is like get
your master's name and it doesn't matter
how much further you fall that's a term
if you have a population of something
that's growing right there's a ray I
wish it's kind of like okay you've got a
people are dying
or animals are dying exactly the same
rate as animals being born yeah so your
mortality rate your birthday they match
up okay but if you have just a little
bit extra it's like oh now we have the
ability to you know breed and grab
population faster than what's being lost
through our deaths in the population so
it's still exponential growth but does
start won't go toward zero and then
lastly this is my attempt at drawing
osmosis in a house closest works right
you've got high concentration and you've
got low concentration and that membrane
is going to slow it down so I'll just
kind of diffuse but eventually it won't
become diffuse right now how quickly
does it diffuse well though all the
differences between the concentrations
roughly speaking you know there are the
factors that are supplying but then what
the difference is then the faster the
osmosis will happen and at some point
the osmosis rules stop when the
difference between them is zero that
means that's when they have same thing
so these environmental factors mean that
our equations of exponential growth are
ever so slightly different so you do
need this table now so if you haven't
got to the point where you've drawn it
go in and enjoy it's not going to be as
involved as the previous one okay but we
just think about normal birth and decay
we have situations like this you can say
your population and it's a to the K T
and we of course know that if it were
decay what would be the difference
there'd be a single people change
yeah we just don't mind saying it right
then then we get the you know it's
dropping off cuz we reflected it
horizontally now we put to this just
earlier the differential equations the
equation that relates the derivative
with the original population of mass or
temperature whatever it's going to be DP
DT it'd be equal to what in this case
it's just gonna be a pain right because
if you differentiate this you're inside
unitive is K and so it comes out in
front and then you just get feedback
with no other changes okay and of course
just like before it would
hey we just have a minus sign in now
what we have a look at this is a
particular corner which is not a very
good name because like what if like what
does that mean this is a bit of a
powerful that's why they preferably the
difference if you're going to have an
extra numbering here like say we call it
and it's just the consonant but offsets
your exponential growth or your
exponential decay right so this is just
an extra cluster there that raises or
lowers program generally okay now all of
the psyche outside of the table let's
think about what kind of differential
equation would result is what gonna be
the same one different function should
have a different differential equation
so let's come back here website if I
were to differentiate this modified
equation not a trick question
what would the derivative be what
happens to be capital n it's a constant
so it goes we did you forget it's gone
okay but what should they get left to it
is
this guy over here which will be K times
yeah a e to the KT almost everything you
had before now if I then say i factor
out that K and this is going to seem a
bit we what I'm about to do but I'm
trying to get in terms of the
differential equation trying to get in
terms of this initial this initial
equation if what I do is I add N and
then take an away let me say that you if
you add in and then take it away there's
no net change right do you agree that
these two equations are the same no
change but the reason why I added then
taken away is because have a look at
this party on what is that that's your
equation that's your original function
for the population with us or
temperature or whatever you were dealing
with right so therefore I find replace
that with P I now have a differential
equation like so which relates the
derivative with the original function
right I've got my came out front and
instead of just having P I've got P take
and that's it okay so you see this
constant here just makes life a lot more
complicated but it does give you
different situations that music like
doing that that and subtracting is
exactly the same so we just and you're
happy with that that's okay now I'm
going to give you a working example this
the first one actually that I did of the
front and it gets a special day because
it gets used so often so this is people
know all about what food which which
visitors doing eggs after what we have
cooling objects we call it Newton's law
of cooling okay so if you want you can
put a little of a little something over
this example we're about to do which is
you tube or a cooling it's worth
pointing out that if you have a hot
object you put it in a cool environment
toward cooling but if the room if you do
the reverse right if you take a cool
objects like a first object and then you
put out and remember John equals four in
exactly the same way okay so I've given
you some fancy let's fill this
information is because I didn't want any
spoilers if it's a 20 degree day
okay so of 20 degrees was the ambient
temperature 20 degrees in normal space
and suppose you boil some water you boil
some water and after five minutes of
cooling reporting to a couple is
important otherwise you pour it into a
cup an ounce in five minutes it hits any
grid so it's cooled down substantially
deposits of two questions and these
exponential growth equation questions
always begin like this you're going to
be required to prove that a particular
function is going to satisfy the
relevant different crazy so prove that
this will satisfy now I've alluded to
this as late as well in situations where
you're dealing with temperature and time
temperature and time both start with T
but we
anyway so I've got capital T the
temperature and little T as we've been
using it a quite some time to militate
this time to time so yes that means my
differential equation will have DT on DT
in it just do it that it'd be fun okay
now what are we going to get okay so our
first part which you're going to do in a
second is to prove that this function
will satisfy this group addition
equation we're gonna do that a second
and then the real question is okay well
how long did that's how long it took 30
degrees how long will it take to get
down to 25 degrees yes I did yeah yeah
there's somebody I should worry about
that because it would be easier to read
so at least rate we say that one will
turn out the least bit more complete
let's prove that this function satisfies
this differential equation improvement
and then secondly let's find out how
long's are going to take how many
minutes whatever to get to this target
turtle